there save me some margaritas
jeff jackson from smith
he's teaching us how to treat mom to a
special dish take a look
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from smith
it's that time of year to celebrate our
mothers happy mother's day um our
mothers need to be taken care of they're
such an important part of our lives and
maybe our cooking skills maybe aren't
quite so good i'm going to show you a
recipe where you don't need to have good
skills but
it's going to be super fancy for anyway
and we're gonna be making um eggs
benedict so there's gonna be hollandaise
sauce eggs benedict uh bread boat so
we're gonna use a loaf of french bread i
have here i'm gonna cut
leaving about a half inch board around
the side and down at an angle i'm going
to cut the middle of it out you don't
need to dig all that out we want to keep
that all in there maybe a little bit but
so it should look like this something
like this if
just try to get a smaller
french bread as if you can okay so let's
make the inside so what i have here is
six eggs i'm gonna hurry and whisk those
up and i'm gonna add some salt and
pepper to those
i'm gonna add some ham you can
substitute bacon if you want it or if
your mom likes vegetables maybe some
asparagus you can
change it up as as much as you'd like
this is some gruyere cheese my favorite
cheese super good then i'm gonna add
some heavy cream to give it some
creaminess so we're gonna mix that all
up maybe a little bit of chive as well
make it nice and fancy not much going on
yet not too fancy not too hard but very
delicious so we're gonna put this in
here
i have my
oven preheating to
about 350.
see if we can get it on there without
making too much of a
mess perfect okay so this is going to go
in the oven 350 for about 15 to 20
minutes or until the egg is set and it's
the bread is toasty let's get that in
there
okay so it's been about 20-25 minutes
and really time is going to vary
depending on the size of your bread and
the i guess the the size of the well
that you created but you're just looking
for the egg to be set which this is and
for the to kind of puff up and be brown
on so that's perfect let's get to our
hollandaise sauce don't be scared of
this it's super easy so what we're going
to do is take some egg yolks and put in
a blender
then we're going to go lemon juice
then we're going to go salt and cayenne
pepper then we're going to go dijon
mustard just about a tablespoon of that
it's about right there okay then we're
going to blend that together really
quickly here
let me get it on there right once this
comes together
it should take about 20 seconds or so
once it does hot butter
just stream the hot butter into it
like so
okay we'll get the rest of that butter
in there
and
it should be done
let's see how we did
should be just a emulsified sauce
looking good let's see how it is we'll
get it out of there into our gravy boat
here
ah perfect see that's perfect
hollandaise sauce that took less than a
minute to make so basically what we're
gonna do is put that on our plate here
we're going to serve that with our
hollandaise sauce your mother's going to
love it happy mother's day thank you so
much for watching thank you for shopping
we will see you next time bye bye
everybody
well thank you again it's miss food and
drug for sponsoring this segment for the
full recipe ingredients and more just
head to their website
smithsfoodanddrug.com